tu est absolument parfaite
et si tu le désires je passerai le reste
de ma vie et m'a pété n'est qu'un club
de golf français pas de faire aussi mal
voilà ce qu'est ce que tu veux je veux
mon pognon c'est tout en ce qu'elle aime
la fin pour sauver tout de suite
tu étais sous moi mêlés à des braquages
de banques
quand on m'a mis sous protection des
témoins je savais que je serais plus
inquiété non non je faisais que conduire
et yahoo
je suis marshall vous voyez egea témoin
sous ma protection qui a besoin de moi
tu es arrivé suis désolé pour m'avoir
menti tepa des années et toi t'en
applique sur des plans à trois j'en sais
rien il a enterré quelque chose qui me
alex on était les meilleurs potes il m'a
trahi
qu'est ce qui te regardent grand père
c'est pas la bonne chance c'est
dégoûtant
[Musique]
c'est vrai
q qu'est ce que tu fous rooney devrait
faire plus attention ferme ta gueule
désolé madame
[Musique]
numéro de bab de quoi tu peur bleue de
la tôle pendant huit mois pas aimer les
équipements djimba sodomie si on me l'a
foutu dans le cul à cause de toi tu es
vraiment désolé c'était un black
non c'était pas black c'est un mexicain
non idan ces fachos c'est ça salit
c'était un pull et ben voila tu es
content de savoir jusqu'où montcuq et
allez voyager